زياره الرئيس الاوكراني فلودي ميرسي يوم
امس الى مدينه خرسون مضمونها وكان شديد
الارتباط بمقاله اليوم في امام رؤساء
مجموعه العشرين طبعا تحدث الرئيس
الاوكراني
عن بدايه نهايه الحرب
وامكانيه يعني امكانيه احلال السلام طبعا
هذا ما ذكر به اليوم في مجموعه العشرين
وتحدث عن خارطه همم صحه تعبير مسوده يعني
خارطه الطريق للسلام تتضمن عشر نقاط
ابرزها الامن النووي في الصداره باعتبار
ان همم روسيا لا تزال تهدد وتعتبر وتستعمل
الطاقه
وهو ما ذكر به امام القاده وكذلك هناك عده
نقاط من بينها الامن الطاقي والغذاء
واسترجاع الاسرى وخاصه العوده الى
المواثيق الدوليه والاتفاق الامم المتحده
الذي في اي يقضي باسترجاع وحده الاراضي
الاخرانيه اي ما يعني خروج القوات الروسيه
بكاملها من كل الاراضي التي استولت عليها
والتي تتبع حسب الوثائق الامميه لاوكرانيا
طبعا الرئيس فولوديمير زينسكي ذكر ايضا
بان البنيه التحتيه الاساسيه في
مدينه خلصن تاثرت ودمرتها القوه الروسيه
بشكل كبير ومكثف وهذا ما لاحظ له يوم امس
طبعا في حديثنا مع عدد من المواطنين
والسكان في مدينه خرسن الذين اكدوا لنا ان
همم يعني هناك انقطاع في التيار الكهربائي
وكذلك انقطاع في الماء وحتى ايضا وسائل
الاتصال
بالانترنت الهاتف لا تعمل لذلك قامت
السلطات المحليه بتوفير عده منشات ومعدات
مؤقته في ساحه الساحه الرئيسيه للمدينه
وقامت بت يعني جهاز للربط عبر الاقمار
الاصطناعيه وكذلك حتى الكهرباء لكي يتمكن
الناس مني شحن هواتفهم طبعا همم في همم في
غضون ذلك تتواصل المعارك وهذا ما لاحظناه
ايه يوم امس ذوي المدافع والصواريخ يعني
متواصله بشكل مسترسل وحتى عند خروجنا من
مدينه خرسا شاهدنا العديد من الصواريخ في
ريفي همم منطقه همم الصواريخ والقذائف
التي تنطلق من الاراضي الاوكرانيه نحو
الجهه المقابله وكذلك حتى اعمده الدخان في
عده مناطق في هذه في اقليم